hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nights at candy's
not been rationing out the five nights
at Freddy's fan games but this one
actually is at the top of a lot of
people's lists it's very highly rated
and apparently candy like the character
was made and used before five nights at
candy's was ever actually a game so I'm
gonna give this one a try I don't know
if I'll make it through all five nights
of it Candy's Burgers and Fries families
restaurant looking for security guard
during the night shift 12a embassy booth
with little dog it's a pretty much
carbon copy of five nights at Freddy's
but maybe it could be good and have some
unique new characters and a lot of
scares I mean that's all I really hope
for out of these games I mean I don't
expect it to be in whoa hello yes hi oh
boy one message hello hello hi jr.
manager here you're the new security
guard right yeah it's great to finally
have someone qualified for the job you
know we have to like share the shift
because you know someone has to be here
during the night but but with you now we
have more energy to be here during the
day
you see we're probably going to be a lot
busier from now on you may have heard
about the place called Freddy fazbear's
pizzeria right uh yeah they got shut
down yesterday I don't know why though
probably something like get tax fraud or
such you know sure yeah I never really
liked that place I always had a bad
feeling about it you know their pizzas
weren't even that good anyway I think
you're going to fit in really well here
the staff are really nice we make sure
to help each other out on everything
like when we close late in the evening
we all make sure that the floors and
tables are probably cleaned and all the
dishes has flashed before we get off of
the day now
in order to save power of course all the
lights will not be turned off but don't
worry we have a desk crammed in the
office that you can use
if you open up the maintenance panel
you'll be able to view the restaurant
through the secured cameras and the
cameras all have a neat feature which is
night vision mode these cameras were the
cheapest we could get so the night
vision isn't that accurate but does
retain the colors
I don't good I guess well you talking
about good welcome to night vision by
activating the camera you're already on
and by the way we have a security
feature in the restaurant that limits
how much power can be used after hours
this is mainly so that our electricity
bill doesn't skyrocket during a night
did somebody forgot to turn off
something somewhere you know now on your
office is also the information area
which you can tell because of the window
counter in front of you there should be
a button underneath a desk - this is for
the security - are in front of your
window not your left and right are also
two doors these doors are a little
stupid
you see they require power to be closed
I think it was something about some
computer or somewhere always checking if
they're closed or not once maybe it was
a security feature you know in case the
place goes dark like if there was a
power outage you know you would be stuck
here but doors open up automatically if
that happens okay um all three doors are
power driven so basically don't use too
much power
otherwise a place will show up
completely but don't worry
as I said doors will open up if that
happens no Joey won't be trapped okay I
think that was all for now yeah good
luck on your first night here
don't fall asleep and have a good night
thank you I'm sure everything will go
wonderfully and I think we'll go Rob get
off I've gotta pee okay okay okay so I
think I'm gonna be okay this is actually
a really interesting mechanic with like
the night vision being like you have to
activate it on command here so I I mean
it's basically the same principle but I
always didn't make sense about how the
doors closed with power but I guess the
safety feature does make a lot of sense
so like
said it's not gonna be a whole lot I got
candy and Cindy here even though candy
and like Karen candy and Katniss are you
the animatronic nightmare that's gonna
haunt all my dreams probably I mean they
seem relatively okay I mean I am chewing
through power but I don't think that's
big of a deal there doesn't seem to be
much of an indication of how much I'm
powering you hey excuse me
hey wait a minute oh god no oh no oh hey
wait that's those there ha ha ha
where's your sister her brother I don't
know are you both girls I don't know I
don't want to do something wrong here hi
it's not exactly night-vision this look
like you just have a lamp hello oh you
look so adorable and cute oh no oh oh oh
god oh no oh hey okay I'm just gonna
keep that door closed
oh no red wreckin flashing means bad I
don't know what they do means yeah who's
that
oh okay I have no idea what's going on
maybe I can leave that open
I mean what's use more power over time
the longer it's open closed I don't know
can i I'm guessing if they're not like
there it's probably not too bad how are
they gonna get through there anyway it's
a window to the wall to the go the freak
away
Oh know where to go pretty go Frick it's
okay
Oh robot scrapped Freddy fazbear is
closing after being open a few short
weeks it's scrapped oh oh great okay all
right let's try that again I didn't know
that he was coming to murder my face off
how was I to know ha ha ha new games new
rules bunch of bullcrap bunch of
bullcrap I say shut up shut up Ned mate
whatever your name may be or may not be
feel like these Knights also lasts a lot
longer I only made it to 4:00 a.m. last
time so long as I say there I should be
relatively okay so I'm just gonna camp
out nap no one better sneak up on me hmm
candy Incendia stupid hmm maybe there's
like an inactivity thing I better not do
nothing because I remember in five
nights at freddys there's definitely an
inactivity thing oh you such adorable
little kitties and this guy's such a
nightmare fuel thingamabob err and then
there's like a picture of a pet there's
like a penguin it's like a picture of a
monkey over there I don't know if you're
all friends or something
but I'd like it if you just went the
[ __ ] away and never bothered me ever in
your life that'd be pretty cool sue
all right okay what is the dinging why
is there dinging
I don't like the dinging could you stop
the digging okay it's gonna happen fat
dole in there that is me I see a pink
mustache back there there's some pink
mustache look how's it big mustache back
on there a lot of heights in this room
the particularly spooky room oh boy
whole lot of waiting around these nights
definitely do last longer which is not
cool cuz failure is more punishing if
that is the case I don't like to fail
everyone makes fire me when I fail no
hey where'd you go hello hi friend how
are you doing just want to keep an eye
on you your sisters still in the other
room that's pretty good right hurt
brother I don't know on a judge judge
free zone no no let's start that [ __ ]
don't start that ball crap Howard you go
where is she oh wait you know what's
that Oh God
okay okay all right good I got you guys
you stay right there
I don't much care for all this wanderer
wooing wanderer whoo oh man come on like
this I don't have to wave through the
whole night again oh my god damn it stay
right there
you bastards huh okay Oh God
okay ones there what's still there once
there I will find poor fellow oh God
hey ah yeah that's what I think you okay
now we got two busy bodies being busy
I'm assuming that that's bad I don't
know how they're gonna be diving through
the window like that but I ain't taking
a risk
I'm gonna run out of power I know for a
fact
mother right out of our you son to
[ __ ] you sassy Sue's dancing all over
the place with your glowing eyeballs
Oh God where did she go ooh there she
was haha good thing that's not lethal to
me and I can take that off yeah
okay I got you both you sassy kitties
you being what cats do Oh Oh Frick Oh
God where is she oh oh that's not good
okay Oh God Oh God oh okay oh okay oh
okay all right
she gonna like jump to another one you
just stay right there buddy
oh god where where where where where
where where oh god okay okay oh good
okay that's only four I am load of
malarkey where do you go okay there he
is it's over there she's back there he's
over there we're okay he's good
okay all right then
oh god that's not good hello you're
getting a little close to creeping up on
me and I don't freeze you oh god oh no
oh no where'd she go
oh good there okay you stay right there
and there we're okay your sassy little
kitties ain't gonna creep up on me
oh god where'd she go okay there she is
looks like a goddamn nightmare trying to
hunt him down in the dark just looking
for the glowing eyeballs among the
static it's not okay with this
it's not okay uh I got the
heebie-jeebies
no why I like dogs better
why was there never a doggie animatronic
maybe there's a dog animatronic in this
patch I think there's a monkey enough
Angwin of God where'd she go Oh No okay
ah got a close yeah one I don't even
know if that's actually effective
because Oh No where'd you go Oh okay
she's there I'm there all right I guess
I mean Zig with that backup oh come on
5:00 a.m. go a little quicker now
anything would be more helpful
that is a halt anything help I'm ascared
yeah okay loading fief what does that
mean what does this mean what is this I
don't know what this is what is this Oh
God
this is some sort of go hey what are you
huh
I don't want to know that's not the baby
I don't want to wake that baby that's
what happens to the baby after you wake
it up huh huh huh huh
can I stop staring at it please how much
long enough I got to do this whoa whoa
whoa hi buddy
hey how's it going there oh god you're
so scary why do I got to do this again
oh you sack of crap you son of a biscuit
you ask plastic okay okay okay all right
then okay all right that's Mexican
really good that was really good
that was super ly well done I can see
why this is one of the highest rated fan
games that was amazing I love that so
anyway let me know in the comments if
you want to see more of this game I'll
gladly play because by far it's probably
one of the best besides one night at
flumpty's I still think one at flumpty's
is the best but this is pretty good so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
oh we G open it up no we go